I have to start with so a lot of people
in this movie are were in Game of
Thrones and Zach must have watched the
show because if you look at the cast a
lot of people were so the big question
is how did you get cast I uh was offer a
role of Game of Thrones and was not able
to do it and so I think Zach must have
heard that in spite of not actually
gracing the screens they did want me so
I had I had passed the Ben off casting
test besides Rubble Moon if someone has
actually never seen anything you've done
before what is the first thing you'd
like them watching and why
uh I don't know for me Children of Men
and it's not Children of Men although
Children of Men is fantastic lost city
is z for me oh yeah it's real good just
the film I'm most proud of other than
Rebel Moon yeah it's uh if I'm thinking
of projects that meant a lot to me uh
one that comes to mind is T for HBO that
was a show that I it's been a while but
it it you know it's uh it holds a
special place in my heart yeah show I
saw every episode of that show David
Simon is a genius that's a whole anyway
um what is the most nervous you have
been the night before the first day of
filming and
why Wow I mean there's I suppose you'd
have to break that down into two
categories beginning of one's career
where everything was just terrifying or
when we were into the career where there
would be something that Peak that um so
I think the latter is probably more
interesting
um I I I again actually unfortunately
lost city is said I had just finished
doing um King Arthur and uh I was about
190 PBS of like pure muscle and I showed
up two days after wrapping actually no
the day after I wrapped for a costume
fitting uh and took my shirt off andreid
director was in the room and literally
started crying when he saw my body and I
went are you okay and he went yeah yeah
yeah you you've just ruined my film no
oh God yeah and uh that was not the look
he was he was going for no that's not
what he was hoping for and so uh I uh
did not eat anything for two weeks and I
dropped 18 pounds in two weeks and
showed up on set but then I was you know
really in my head for that first day of
filming like did I really just ruin his
film I ruined it first of all thank you
for sharing that's a great story and for
me I think um it is probably early in my
career um after I just moved to the
states uh which is now probably about 14
15 years ago you know starting as an
actor from abroad from the Netherlands
in my case starting to work in in a
language that's not your first language
is so terrifying in the beginning and it
took me years to be comfortable with
that you know um and so I I very very
vividly remember uh you know the night
before the first day of shooting and
thinking like oh my God I can't speak I
don't know how to do this somehow I I
survived I guess I mean yeah you landed
on your still doing it yeah I got to say
25 years now I'm if you feel like this
the first day of every job is all is is
still terrifying because it's all of
this Theory and all of this hope and
work and then you got to show up and
actually do it and let it go also you
could have the Eric stal situation and
Back to the Future where you're a few
days in and all of a sudden the
director's like this is the wrong person
for this role yes you can there you can
have that too been there I I I got I got
replaced I had not started filming they
replaced the director and the director
didn't want me but I'd been attached to
it for a long time and done all of these
rehearsals and so you even should I ask
the project or should I not uh Ruma has
it okay let's jump into Rebel moon since
otherwise Netflix and the green room is
GNA only do you know what Steve only you
I would have actually answered that
question I hope you understand that by
the way thank you and uh I'm gonna
sincerely thank you so with Rebel Moon
there is a lot of cool in this
movie what is something in part one
and part two that you are looking
forward to audiences
seeing well I'm oh my God what do I look
forward to I mean there were a couple of
moments I must say there's one moment
the benu the Banu Mo the Banu
flight yeah number one I first time I
saw the film I've seen it a few times
now first time I saw it I did I love
stars like I be I love that man with all
my heart and so seeing him and that's
such a iconic moment for him and his
character that that moment happened in
part one and I punched the air yeah I
agree that's a fantastic moment and also
in general both in part one and part two
I can't wait for the world to see what a
badass Sophia is as Kora yeah you're
right like and and yeah I mean I think
we were all really in awe by how she
approached and and dedicated herself to
all the all her stunt work yeah I I read
that she did like a ridiculous amount
and the thing about her performance is
you need well yeah but you also need to
believe she is can kick everyone's ass
in every room and and she delivers that
yeah yeah yeah I agree because in real
life she probably can't that dancing
background definitely works yeah you
know what I mean um so one of the things
that is really cool about this film is
that it's really hard to make original
Ip nowadays and I think it's great that
Netflix and Zach are bringing something
like this to life so can you sort of
talk about the fact that like big movies
like this are really hard to get a green
light and being a part of something like
this that it's just original yeah well
and especially for what I felt as a
filmmaker um to to to be to get free
Reigns you know I feel like this really
is the world that Zach had in mind yeah
the film that he wanted to make it does
not feel like there's a single
compromise been made you know between
Zach and the studio it feels like it's
absolutely Zach and we've you know I
think it's really true to be able to
have um to be it's such a privilege to
be able to go and make original original
tell Original Stories on this scale but
then to be have as much latitude to be
as rock and roll in the process as punk
rock in that Zach wasn't precious the
stud Studio wasn't precious it was a
really sort of exciting and free form
process actually shooting this which is
unheard of we were joking about it
normally if you want that much creative
control you don't also get paid anything
like you go and make that for about
$200,000 and no one ever sees it and we
all have a lovely time feeling like real
artists Super Creative yeah very rare
you get to feel this creative on on
something of this scope on that note I
really do hope it's a huge hit for you
guys thank you for sharing some good
stories and good luck with the rest of
your speed dating you are the
greatest